also want to wish peter belated happy
birthday um
glad to see that he's just staying a
little bit ahead of me there um
so i don't have the distinction of being
the oldest coach in the league
bill belichick earlier this week giving
a little a little business to pete
carroll when he turned 69 we're gonna
give the business to tom curran who
apparently is out finishing his round at
the u.s open today tom curran welcome
back how are you i should say welcome
you've never been on this new show on
peacock so welcome to peacock welcome to
pftpm what's up
thank you very much i couldn't be
happier to be on peacock than i am right
now um and it could be happier to be
with you with sheree i'm trying to lean
the correct way and i think i just
figured it out right there so we're at
the barren hills country club coming
live
um from the knights fairway which i'm
not in i'm in my pocket
no way in hell that anyone would ever
let you in a country club
well i mean it's involved
the things i have the hoops i have to
jump through michael but i'll tell you
um how are you guys doing
we're doing good and you know bill
belichick giving the business to pete
carroll they're both getting closer to
70. i asked robert craft several years
ago how long he'd like bill belichick to
coach kraft said i want to see him be
like rupert murdoch
warren buffett
coach into his 80s
how long do you think bill belichick is
going to keep going
i don't really see any end in sight mike
and
the fact that his two sons are on the
staff now brian and stephen both and you
know i think stephen is the de facto
defensive coordinator at this juncture
and we'll see if he ends up being named
defensive coordinator brian is now um
also in the secondary where stephen was
so
i don't see any reason that he would
want to reboot a special or retire
because there is a reboot going on
that i think bill feels really good
about so
certainly not within the next three
years
tom we heard
bill belichick rave about russell wilson
earlier this week and it didn't sound
like lou holtz where he's just making
stuff up i mean he truly sounded genuine
how much he thinks of of russell wilson
russell wilson's played against him
three times twice in the regular season
has over 600 passing yards six
touchdowns in those two regular season
games and of course we know how the
super bowl ended
how does bill belichick and that and
that patriots defense defend russell
wilson this week
it's really interesting shireen because
what russell wilson did in that super
bowl he didn't complete a pass in 2014
until five minutes and 36 seconds
remained in the first half and the
reason was the patriots said you know
what we're not going to rush him we're
not going to allow him to break the
pocket we're going to stay very very
disciplined and keep him in front of us
now they could do that with a veteran
defense can they do that with a younger
defense can they do that kind of mush
rush keep russell wilson in the pocket
keep them from breaking contain and have
success there so that's what they're
going to try to do
but whether or not they're able to
succeed at that is obviously the
question we're gonna get answered for a
sunday night now the patriots were
terrific last week as much as we talked
about cam newton defensively last week
it's what i was really impressed by
especially with all the options and free
agent departures that they had can they
do it again fighting up a weight class
against russell wilson d.k metcalf
the story is russell wilson versus cam
newton and tom when i saw bill
belichick's comments from monday
downplaying the 15 rushing attempts that
cam newton had on sunday he basically
said hey look there were option plays
sometimes you hand it off sometimes you
keep it and then i watched the game
carefully there were seven designed runs
and there were six runs out of an option
look so
there were plenty of moments where they
called his number and they knew they
were calling his number and i just can't
help but wonder whether or not bill's
trying to throw people off the scent of
what he's really up to and i think we're
going to see plenty of cam newton
running as long as it's effective and
you know what for the most part they
kept him from getting banged around
which is one of the most important
things you have to do with cam newton do
you think we're going to see let's say
15's the bar are we going to see over
are we going to see under 15 rushing
attempts this week
i think it'll be well under i'll be
surprised if he gets to 10. the reason
being different front they're gonna play
that one gap penetrating get up the
field type uh of defense in seattle
whereas miami was playing two gap and
reacting i think too with cam
you're gonna want to take the ball out
of his hands now that you've seen how
capable he is and then he can be a force
of nature still so bobby wagner jamal
adams those are guys you say you know
what make sure the cam decides to hand
it off only michelle or the rex burkhead
on this particular play and to your
point mike
those 15 carries i counted maybe three
where i would say he took punishment on
the tackle um all those carries are not
created equal you might play the ravens
you might play the seahawks you might
play the pittsburgh steelers and have
six carries and take more punishment
than he took last week against miami
which was a lot of single solo tackles
dragged down as opposed to big hits
tom everybody's raving about the
patriots after that game last week and i
think maybe we overrated the dolphins a
little bit i thought they would be
better than than what they seem to do
ryan fitzmagic looked like ryan fitz
turnover in that game
what do we know about the patriots at
this point after that game against the
dolphins
we know that cam newton
has a running style
that
still in 2020 is like it was in 2015. we
know that the patriots have an offensive
line that absolutely positively warmed
to the task of blocking for him
those two things we know about the
offense and we know in the secondary the
patriots are still absolutely loaded we
don't know how their linebackers are
going to look
we don't know how their front is
necessarily going to look against a guy
like russell wilson and we have not seen
and had exposed to us the lack of
weapons that they have on offense so
all we know is cam newton offensive line
secondary jack park check mark check
mark
all right tom get back to your round how
many balls have you lost today
uh it's funny because when i play with
my kids it's awful and i've probably
lost at least six so i'm trying to break
even every time i go in the woods
lose one all right have fun
thank you thank you for taking time away
from your kids i'm sure they're glad to
get a break from you for a few minutes
now they'll be disappointed that you
come back see you tom
all right guys
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports